people have been asking for an update on
the story from Monday I told you Monday
that police at UC Berkeley were filmed
ticketing and taking earned money from a
hot dog vendor who didn't have a permit
for selling hot dogs Martin Flores
filmed the incident I've been in touch
with Martin via Facebook here is just a
reminder of this incident you're gonna
take it Arden people could drink on
campus on football games and no tickets
but a hard-working man
selling hotdogs earning a living get
their money taken away no it's not like
I see people drinking in public on
campus who are not working fellas
I'm telling you right now go down walk
toward your feet your left and you'll
see drinking in public but a
hard-working man gets his money taken
away and a ticket that's not working for
you not for me brother not for me and
I'm disappointed as an alumna
disappointed in this campus why you
disappointed on me because because I
stand up for somebody's working on this
in critical thinking every time I see it
it gets more insane so here's the update
Martin Flores started a GoFundMe
campaign over seventy eight thousand
dollars have been raised for this vendor
I've been in touch with Martin Flores
who filmed this he ran the GoFundMe he
found the vendor he did some interviews
he said he's in
credibly inspired by the support that
there's been the original goal was to
raise $10,000 which would be enough to
take care of the ticket to get the lost
money back to the vendor and to get him
a push cart as well to start a better
business and of course get the permit
that he was told he didn't have seventy
eight thousand dollars have now been
raised it's gonna remain open for a
couple more weeks and they're gonna be
using the money to actually help
multiple street food vendors this is
turning into a whole thing as I like to
say and truly an incredible story and
tons of reaction from our audience many
people saying David the ticket was
appropriate the guy didn't have a permit
will then tell him to go get the permit
but don't seize his money and that's the
x-factor that pushed this to go
completely viral over the last five days
yeah that was my whole take on it I mean
he was in the wrong for not having a
permit but it just seemed as if he was
being made a mockery of because you take
his money and everything else and it was
a whole scene but you know seventy eight
thousand dollars that can go a long way
not just for Juan but for other vendors
as well I think it's a good thing the
whole point is it's not really about
improving society that seems to be the
priority of some of these law
enforcement actions or making things
better for everybody this was an
opportunity to take money from some guy
and tell him to go away and it was all
legal because of the system that we have
and the people I haven't heard from that
I would love to hear from are the police
officers that were involved in this what
is their point of view now I wonder what
they're thinking given that seventy
eight thousand dollars has been raised
with the with the help of Martin Flores
an incredible story and we'll give you
the final fundraising total in a week or
two when it's all done